by 45 into Wednesday morning hey we're
losing lanes on the south end of the 15
get ready for a repaving squeeze play
for both directions of the 15 between
Silverado ranch and Sloane over the next
12 days Nevada Department of
Transportation says it's going to be
taking places in phases with different
stretches of each direction losing the
two right lanes from eight each evening
until 5:00 the following morning so it
starts tonight along the northbound
lanes between Sloan and Starr tomorrow
night Thursday night into Friday the
work will continue northbound from Starr
up to Silverado ranch no works going to
take place over the weekends but then
those same two northbound right lanes
between star and Silverado ranch closed
Sunday night into Monday morning into
Tuesday morning Monday night they'll
turn around and close the two right
lanes of the southbound 15 between
Silverado ranch and Starr now rather
than go through the rest of each nights
lane restrictions may I invite you to
visit our website eight News now.com
click on traffic and then click driving
you crazy and look for this eye 15
repaving squeeze play stories who will
have each day's work
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there's something
driving you crazy email me traffic eight
eight News now.com